How is twenty twenty for you, Superfund, right?
Well, if you believe the predictions of Nostradamus and you enjoyed 20 20, you're going to
love what happens next.
Today, we're going to cover his famous prophecies of the past and what's in store for the
future.
So grab your magic, mirror your tinfoil hat and your anti zombie spray because we get a
wild one.
Welcome to the Y files, where cool nerds laugh and learn.
So you thought things couldn't get any worse, huh?
Things can always get worse.
They certainly can, and Nostradamus says they will.
While many astrologers, seers and mystics are predicting a hopeful future.
If you believe Nostradamus, you better start kissing your mommies and saying your
goodbyes.
He predicted that 20 20 would be a great trouble for humanity and well, that was true.
But he also says a greater trouble is coming and that greater trouble is supposed to take
the form of a global famine.
According to Nostradamus, the famine will be the worst the world has ever faced and will
ultimately end in a disruption of social hierarchies and state power.
Now, this prediction does have some merit based on what's happening in the world right
now.
The pandemic has already forced millions of people to food banks and depleted food
supplies around the world.
Even the United Nations warned that we are looking at famines of biblical proportions.
Those are the UN's words.
Now, I'm not a religious scholar, but whenever something is described in biblical
proportions, it's never good news.
And why it is super rich buying up all the farmland they are.
No wake up, will you?
We need to look into that. So what else is coming our way?
Well, Nostradamus predicted solar storms will take place, causing major damage to the
earth.
We should see the water rising and falling under it.
Then he predicts a comet or asteroid will hit the earth or come very close to striking the
planet.
And this event will cause earthquakes and other natural disasters in the sky.
One cease fire and a long career of sparks fly.
We did have some pretty close calls with asteroids in the past year.
And NASA's automated asteroid watching system called Century is currently tracking
asteroid two thousand nine, JF one and JF one is about one hundred and thirty meters in
diameter. It's about the size of the Great Pyramid of Giza that would hit the Earth
sometime in twenty, twenty two.
And if it does, the impact would measure about two hundred and thirty kilotons.
Now for perspective, Hiroshima was only about 15 kilotons.
So yeah, JF one is a city killer or worse.
And if things weren't bad enough in California, Nostradamus also predicts the state of
California will be destroyed by a massive earthquake within the next year.
Nostradamus predicted a great calamity that would shake through the new world in the
lands of the West, causing it to fall into the ocean.
This is thought to be California Melchiorre and Sagittarius, Saturn Fadime and a date with
Mars and Saturn will be in those exact positions.
In the sky is Thanksgiving Day, November.
Twenty fifth, twenty twenty one.
So if you're in California for Thanksgiving, don't fight over drumsticks, fight over life
rafts, you're going to be underwater.
That doesn't sound so big.
And the last prediction is a doozy.
Two words, zombie apocalypse.
It was just a matter of time.
Here's the text. Few young people have dared to give a start phases in Mozes date of
infinite sorrows.
Women in mourning, the pestilence she monsta the one to be no more.
Some believe this pestilent she monster symbolizes a virus or biological weapon that will
bring on the apocalypse.
Should we be nervous? How accurate is Nostradamus?
Well, some websites say he's been 70 percent accurate.
That's pretty good. So let's look at some of his more famous predictions that came true
and learn more about the man than we can see if all those headlines are just social media
click bait or or the world to end.
Has a Nostradamus prediction ever come true?
Well, it's hard to name some significant global event that he has not predicted and his
predictions go all the way back to when he was still alive.
Nostradamus may have accurately predicted the untimely demise of Henry, the second king of
France, who was only 40 when he died, jousting in fifteen fifty nine.
The young lion we overcome the older one on the field of combat.
In a single battle, he would have his eyes through a golden cage to wounds made one.
Then he dies a cruel death.
Let's break down the prediction.
The young lion will overcome the older one.
As Henry was jousting Gabrielle Delors, one of his young soldiers when he was killed,
they both had lions on their shields and Henry actually wore armor shaped like a lion.
How do we know? Well, Henry's armor still around Pierce's eyes for a golden cage.
So during the joust, the young lions lance shattered, driving splinters through the
king's visor and into his eyes and skull, creating two wounds.
And yes, the armor was gold.
As for the cruel death, Henry was still conscious after his injury.
He even got up and walked.
Though he was a mess, the king experienced seizures, partial paralysis, and despite
having the best medical care available at the time, he died in agony of sepsis.
Eleven days later.
So creepy. Yeah, uncanny.
I think so. And with that prediction, the legend of Nostradamus was born.
How about the great fire of London?
Blood of Z just recommitted for dead London battle through lightning of twenty three six.
The ancient lady will fall from her happiness.
Several of the same sect will be killed.
Some interpret twenty threes the six as sixty six or twenty times three plus six.
This is why it's believed to be a prophecy of the Great Fire of London in sixteen sixty
six where thousands of people were killed.
As for the same sect, Londoners blame the fire on Catholics.
The ancient lady is thought to refer to London itself.
Here's one about the French Revolution from the enslaved populace.
Songs, chants and demands like princes and lords held captive in prisons, Zeze will, in
the future by Hitler's
idiots, be received as divine and pass.
When the best deal was stormed in seventeen eighty nine, the French overthrew the monarchy
and established a new republic.
And the third estate, or commoners, a.k.a.
the enslaved populace, declared nobles to be traitors.
We all remember what happened to nobles during the French Revolution.
They became hapless idiots.
Now let's get more current.
Many believe Nostradamus predicted the rise of Hitler from the depths of the west of
Europe, a young child will be born of poor people.
Hitler was born in Austria and came from a lower to middle class family, except he who by
his tongue will seduce a great tooth.
His film will increase towards the end of the east and his younger days, his military
career was undistinguished.
He didn't have money or influence, but he did know how to whip up a crowd with a speech
kicks out beasts ferocious with hunger across the Vivace
conquered Europe and just a few years and always wanted more.
The greatest part of the battlefield will be against his death.
And that's just one letter off.
It's pretty creepy and greater part of the battlefield.
Hitler fought and defeated much bigger armies during his rise.
Now, how about the atomic bombs at Hiroshima and Nagasaki visiting two days?
There will be scads is the like of which has never seen there was never an attack like
this before or since shakes out.
Famine was in plague.
People put down by the kind of the great immortal God for relief.
And this is possibly about radiation sickness and the lasting pain of war.
And people put out by steel could be the planes which dropped the bombs or buildings
collapsing or the cities themselves.
Hiroshima and Nagasaki were chosen as targets because they were industrial cities with a
lot of factories.
They created planes, tanks, cars, ships, all from steel.
What about the assassination of JFK?
The engine task will be completed from on high.
Evil will fall on the great man.
Well, depending on who you ask, the order to assassinate JFK came from on high up a dead
innocent to be accused of the deed.
Lee Harvey Oswald was accused and killed.
Was he innocent yet?
Obviously, the guilty will remain in the mist.
If Lee Harvey Oswald was innocent, that means the guilty did remain.
They're still out there.
Let's get even more current.
Did Nostradamus see the 9/11 attacks to steal birds fall from the sky on the propolis, the
steel birds have to be planes and the
metropolis, New York jets out of the sky, the next forty five degrees.
New York is 40 degrees latitude.
But that's that's pretty close.
Fire approaches the great new CD immediately.
A huge scattered flame leaps up.
New York was a new city when Nostradamus was alive and the fire in flames leaping up.
Yeah, that happened.
We see moths.
The undead will roll on the air.
That sounds like zombies.
Now, obviously, there were no zombies after 9/11, but I'm from New York every day as a
New Yorker, we expected another attack.
New Yorkers weren't actual zombies after 9/11, but we acted like them.
How about the death of Princess Diana?
Nostradamus has a lot to say about her penultimate son of the man who is the prophet's
name.
We'll bring Diana to Dallas in nineteen ninety seven.
Diana tragically died in a car crash fleeing from paparazzi, also killed with her
boyfriend, Dodi Fayed, the second to last son or penultimate son of Mohammed Al Fayed.
And Mohammed is indeed the name of a prophet whose upon the middle of the world, because
of nudes, public blood is shed.
Diana was England's rose and her blood was definitely shed publicly.
We all saw it. Her new deeds could be her love affair with Fayed, which the royals lots
of things are then.
Yeah, I noticed that then at a time of need, the awaited one will come late.
Diana spent two hours injured and bleeding in the car before she was taken to the
hospital.
They were too late by the great number of tears shed from top to bottom and from the
bottom to the very top.
All classes of people grieved her death from the very rich, down to the very poor.
Life is lost to a game with too much faith.
Diana was constantly hounded by the paparazzi, and her driver on repoll would often take
them on high speed chases.
To him, it was a game and she had faith in his game.
For the joyful made in the splendour will shine no more indeed.
So who was this mythical figure?
Well, here is his legendary story.
Nostradamus was born, Michel, stardom in France in fifty three and he led an
extraordinary life.
A Jew who converted to Christianity, he inherited his abilities from the Israelite tribe
of Isaac.
He was educated by his grandfathers who were doctors in the court of King Renea of
Provence.
Nostradamus went to Montpellier in fifteen twenty one to study medicine and was so
successful that he stayed and became a respected teacher.
Now, after his wife and two children died from the plague, he studied and then became an
expert on the disease.
He used advanced antiseptics.
He recommended a diet low in fat with plenty of exercise.
A noted astronomer, he deduced that the planets went around the sun even before
Copernicus.
Famous for his prophecies, he was persecuted during the Spanish Inquisition for heresy.
He was even placed on the Vatican's index of forbidden books in 1780.
One Nostradamus adopted a very public religious lifestyle to protect himself.
But in private, he continued his mystical pursuits.
Once in Italy, he bowed before a young Franciscan friar for no apparent reason.
Later, that young friar became the pope.
He knew. He knew.
His books of prophecies called The Centuries, are written in codes and anagrams.
The book sold so well that Nostradamus became a celebrity in his own time to assist him
in writing his predictions, he used a bowl of water which he called a magic mirror.
In fact, in PRESTAGE one forty one, Nostradamus predicted the date of his own death.
In fifteen sixty seven, he had himself buried upright so that nobody can walk in his
grave.
In fact, when his body was exhumed during the French Revolution, workers were amazed to
find him wearing a medallion engraved with that very day's exact date.
Whoa. Now, that is a great story.
And I've heard it my whole life.
And you can read this all over the Internet.
It's perfect.
The problem is none of it's true.
What? Now that we've covered the myths, let's look at the facts now, Michelle Nostradamus
did lead an extraordinary life,
but he was not a Jew who converted to Christianity.
One of his grandfathers did, but he didn't.
He inherited nothing special from the Isaac tribe.
He had no grandfathers who were doctors in the royal court or anywhere.
He didn't study medicine in Montpelier.
He never went there.
Definitely didn't teach there.
Actually, during that time, he wandered the countryside from fifteen, twenty one to
fifteen, twenty nine and taught himself apothecary.
His wife and two children did die from disease, but probably wasn't the plague.
He didn't use antiseptics.
Nobody did. And he didn't recommend a low fat diet or exercise, though that's still a
good idea.
He made no discoveries about the solar system and his only alleged contact with the
Inquisition was an invitation to comment on metallurgy and bronze casting.
Being on the Vatican's index of forbidden books sounds pretty bad ass, but he wasn't on
it.
He was actually on good terms with the church, which is probably why he was invited to be
a guest speaker at Inquisition or whatever that was that kneeling before the young pope
story. Pure fiction never happened.
As far as his fame.
Nostradamus prophecies were virtually unknown during his lifetime, but he did gain some
notoriety from writing cookbooks.
I'm sorry, did you think cookbook skip cookbooks, you know, recipes for how to cook a
nice piece of fish food.
You also wrote almanacs that sold pretty well, but they weren't very accurate.
His prophecies were not called the centuries.
They were called the prophecies.
They were not written in code.
They were in rhyming verse.
Oh, like that is trying to get us canceled.
Nostradamus did not use a bowl of water is his magic mirror.
When he was writing, his prophecies were composing his poems.
He used a regular mirror.
I'll leave it to you to determine whether it's magic or not.
He missed the year of his death by one, although some versions of his writing show the
date was later changed, which probably doesn't count.
He was not buried upright and there's no record of any medallion or anything else with a
date written anywhere.
But the only well known fact that's true about Nostradamus is that he was a fairly
reputable plague doctor, though he admitted himself that he never found any cures or
preventative measures that actually worked.
Really deflating my balloon.
I know I felt the same way.
Sorry about that. So if the story about his life is mostly myth, what about his
predictions?
Can they be believed? Nostradamus remains famous over four hundred years after his death
for a fifteen fifty five book he wrote titled The Prophecies.
The book is a collection of over a thousand quatrains, which are for line rhyming verses
which are said to foretell the future.
Now, depending on who you believe, Nostradamus has been credited with accurately
predicting Hiroshima, Hitler, the space shuttle disaster, the Apollo moon landing, both
world wars, the current pandemic on and on, everything that ever happened, he called it.
In fact, good luck finding some significant global event that Nostradamus was not said to
have predicted.
The truth is, nobody has ever used Nostradamus writings to predict a future event.
Never one time that ever once, never.
So why do so many people still believe for the same reason I wrote this episode, for the
same reason you clicked on it?
It's fascinating and fun.
Nostradamus is a great story and we never let the facts get in the way of a great story.
So what went wrong?
Well, the problem with Nostradamus is predictions is how his writing is translated and
then interpreted.
He wrote in middle French and you really can't do a word for word translation into
English or even modern French.
When his writing is translated, there's a little poetic license required to fill in the
gaps.
And that's OK. There are certain translations of Dante's Divine Comedy, which was written
in vulgar Italian that are better than other translations.
There is a certain creativity to it, but nobody's building bunkers based on DONTAE.
And if you are awesome and Nostradamus was not really specific about anything, his verses
are all symbolism and allegory.
You can make any story fit if you want to be.
Nostradamus talks about a great lady.
Does he mean a literal lady or does he mean a country or a city?
Well, depends on what you want the end result of the prophecy to be.
It's kind of like reverse engineering the prophecy.
You know what event took place.
Now you just go back and make the prophecy fit.
If you have to be a little creative, so be it.
The most creative of Nostradamus interpreters and the one that I first read was also an
ardent believer.
That was Erika Cheatham.
She's best known for reinterpreting Nostradamus reference to history as a reference to
Hitler.
But his daughter was actually a part of the Danube River that Nostradamus knew quite
well, and Cheatham adjusted her translations to suit the times.
Occasionally, she made future predictions, and when they didn't happen, she'd issue
updates of her books with new names and new dates.
First, Nostradamus was talking about Moammar Gadhafi and later changed that to Ayatollah
Khomeini and then later changed it to Saddam Hussein.
Now, whether this is dishonest or not is really how you view the subject matter.
I think the stories are fascinating and absolutely worthy of study, but every prophecy
has to be taken with a whole lot of salt.
For instance, most of the quotes I used earlier are complete fiction, but I didn't make
them up.
I found everything. One of them on a website claiming that Nostradamus wrote them, he
didn't write them all the 9/11 stuff about steel birds, Nostradamus wrote none of that.
Those lines were added after the 9/11 attacks and just became part of the folklore, even
the quatrains about King Henry's death.
You know, the prophecy that made him famous.
Turns out the young lion lines were added years later.
Look, Michelle did Nostradamus really was a brilliant man who lived a remarkable life.
That's true. He made important contributions to medicine and literature.
But was he a prophet?
I don't think so. But his predictions, they create clicks.
Yeah, sorry about that. So why is it so easy to believe Nostradamus through the course of
human history, every major event has been connected with some kind of
prophecy. In one thousand A.D., everyone thought the world is going to end in two
thousand.
Same thing. We called it Y2K, but it was the same psychology.
I remember the great Mayan calendar scare of twenty twelve same psychology.
People look for answers and prophecies because they suggest the disaster couldn't have
been avoided.
It is part of a larger plan and there's comfort in that.
The human mind is wired to create order from chaos to see patterns and connections, even
when none really exist, to be in control of our minds and our environment.
All the anger you see right now among politicians in the news and definitely on social
media, it comes from fear of losing control.
A disease is spreading.
The wrong people are in charge.
Your sports team lost.
You may not have control of those situations.
And that's stressful. And it makes you afraid and it makes you angry.
So what prophecies of Nostradamus do I believe?
Well, none of them, though.
If we all turn into zombies, you can tell me I told you so in the comments.
But what I do believe in is the resilience of the human spirit.
We've been through hard times in this.
We got through them. We did.
Once you strip away our labels, we're just people and we all have fear and we all get
angry.
And that anger has driven us apart.
We don't need a prophet to tell us this too shall pass.
And when a disaster strikes, it's easier to get through it when people set aside their
fear and work together.
Easier said than done.
Thanks for hanging out with us today.
My name is A.J. That tilefish.
This has been the Y files.
If you had fun or learned anything today, subscribe like share, do all that stuff.
The algorithm is a again, but with your help we can defeater Baba Yaga until next time.
Be safe, be kind and know that you are appreciated.